foreign
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of careful boys today we have
with a special guest Christian Pierce
[Applause]
of a really good situation where you
wanted to ask him something I thought
was really interesting
so Christian's a part of the same era
that when we were doing skits and stuff
on YouTube and um it's been pretty much
10 years ish since then right around
that time yeah but a lot has changed
people's tastes in comedy and what is
acceptable and all that stuff has
changed and I feel like it's gotten to
this point where
people don't even talk about the change
openly that much right and what's okay
and what's whatever it's just this taboo
topic but I wanted to hear your thoughts
on like all the things that's changed in
comedy and you're still working in the
industry
um and I feel like
I'm out of touch because I'm not in
Hollywood I just do whatever I want on
YouTube but then
even we like had a how do what do you
call it like scale it back or be careful
in a lot of ways but um
how do you feel about the climate today
and and and do you miss the past or do
you like where it's going or like yeah I
don't love words I mean it's hard man
because I'm always going to be down with
like progress and like things moving
forward like you know just that's it's
inevitable you can't fight time you know
I mean you better like figure out a way
to like find your lane but with YouTube
and like comedic content in that space I
will say there was a big shift between
like when we were doing our thing and
now and I think it was because when we
were doing our thing we were watching
traditional media movies TV and trying
to be like okay the thing that we see
here is like come with original ideas
and make your version of it put it up
you know your fans come then after us
the thing became conform it became like
do what everyone else is doing all right
yeah it was less about true it's about
do original thing and just do what
everyone else is doing because the value
is less about the idea and it was more
about getting famous yeah the algorithm
yeah and like getting everyone was just
copying each other yeah right yeah it
was like it wasn't about like making
good [__] oh [__] you are proud of it's
about getting views every time I go talk
to kids like I've been talking to kids
at whatever conventions and schools and
stuff for years what do you do when you
grow up every single time with Outfield
they all say I want to be famous it's
like the biggest thing you hear it
sounds like a joke almost but I've been
everywhere and like that's the first
thing they say it's like all right we're
gonna take that seriously they're like
what does that mean it's like that's
what is a value to them not making
something not even a YouTuber just being
famous I don't [__] how this doesn't
matter yeah because when we were on
YouTube coming up we wanted to be good
at that thing like music sketch comedy
whatever skill that we wanted to do I
mean Fame was just because they love
what you did not because of
because you have a lot of followers
right right that's yeah it's weird bro
and like it's ultimately lazy you know
what I mean and like I think the
internet and just like phones have done
this to us like we want the quickest
route to something yeah you want food
now you have to order it like you want
to hit a laugh now you go to it it's
instant right so it's like we want to be
famous now we want because that comes
with money or comes with this and that
people so to think and with comedy it's
tough because I think cancel culture is
a lot of the same laziness or it's like
people get canceled not because everyone
has like voted like yeah this is a bad
thing this person shouldn't talk anymore
it's because it's way easier to push a
hard problem to the side and keep moving
than like dive in and dissect it so you
have a few things happening like comedy
is like dwindling on you know the
internet which is like the main source
of everything because people are just
trying to do what everyone else is doing
so it becomes less original and just
becomes a smaller pot and then if
someone makes a joke that's a little bit
more out there and more original that
might ruffle some feathers it's like get
them the [__] out of here
sit down sit down original idea I don't
know
what you know what I mean oh man yeah I
thought it was really interesting how um
it's almost flipped to where like
it's it's almost like um instead of
being original and pushing against the
grain
what's conforming now is what used to be
revolutionary so like so like let's say
um
I don't know like like gay was taboo
back in the day but Gay's now mainstream
right so then things there it's almost
like people are still fighting this
fight that doesn't exist anymore but
you're actually the mainstream yeah oh
actually yeah it's like it's like
there's no reason to fight you don't
need to fight against this there's no
like whatever but then there's a lot of
groups like I think that's happening so
in comedy things feel like oh you can't
talk about that no more and I'm like
wait why they're not a persecuted
persecuted group and then if you treat
it like that that's even worse yeah
right yeah I think it'll come back I
think racism coming back for sure
that's what I'm wishing
the conforming people are now like the
mainstream but then that's gonna get
super oversaturated as it already is and
then it's just gonna repeat it's gonna
bust out I'm tired of [__] being so
PC yeah yeah people are waiting right
yeah people are waiting it is crazy how
the internet and the whole algorithm and
even the implications
of the algorithm has changed the the
landscape of Comedy because I to me I'm
like the the purest form of Comedy to me
is stand up right it's you you're Mike
and your audience your immediate
audience your immediate feedback but
even then the biggest comedians now
aren't really the best comedians it's
the ones with podcasts if you have a
podcast and you can blow and that is
subject to the game of the internet yeah
so if you're good at the game of the
internet then your podcast is huge and
if you're huge your tour is Big Book
right crazy the only like great that
constantly gets booked is Dave Chappelle
but there's a lot of really insanely
good comedians that are kind of
overshadowed because they don't have
podcasts right and it's just crazy how
the whole yeah the whole landscape just
changed yeah I think you have to be if
you love their if you love your craft so
much you better find a way to adapt yeah
you can't be like I love this [__] like
but I'm not doing a [__] podcast well
then you don't [__] love it enough
bro
and it actually makes your life easier
because I see the reason why AI stand-up
comedy changes because in the past right
the only way to see a stand-up comedian
was if you went to a comedy club and
then you don't know this person so the
comedian has to build rapport in such a
short period of time whereas like if you
fall upon a podcast there's so much time
to just get to know and build that
Rapport so then when you get to the
stage they could be even funnier because
you have that oh I remember that story
he told on that yeah okay and then he
couldn't Advance on it so like I almost
feel like that's what's happening in
media too right so if you watch like
traditional news they have a format they
have a method they have a way they have
to just have to quickly get through an
interview and then a lot of the times it
comes off inauthentic it comes off like
[__] up because they're looking for
like sound bites so they're trying to
trigger an emotion and then people hate
that style of interview now so then they
see traditional media as like you're a
bunch of you're full of [__] but it's
just because they're locked into this
old format and I'm thinking maybe
comedies involved in that sense too
where like now you can build like months
of rapport with your favorite comedian
and then when you see them at a show
it's a completely different experience
than when you were if you were to just
walk into like seeing a stand-up
comedian like Breakthrough like real
quick and and make you laugh and then
you got those jokes because it's it's
just funny and you don't you don't know
this person but that's why I think
what's crazy is I think stand-up
comedians are actually turning into
influencers because that community
building that Rapport that's not sound
of Comedy yeah
it's changing a definition yeah it's
like a true I think a true stand-up
comedian makes you laugh about things
you disagree with yeah that's like
that's why that's why Comics are just
powerful too this rock is great like
things like I took a hard stance on this
and they flip your script on you yeah oh
[__] I see things Yeah a different way
or so you're afraid of yeah yeah she's
laughing that's why comedy's power yeah
Louis CK like all the grace of that
right but if they make you laugh at
inside jokes then that's just being like
an influencer or a commercial right yeah
art of stand-up comedy is like is
morphing into something else yeah yeah
I'm sorry no I was just saying like
we're at dinner last night David was
talking about how like all these
stand-up comedians like old school
standard comedians their new specials
now are kind of like less funny and like
less about the jokes and just more about
like talking about life and being a
little bit more serious of its own yeah
you know what I mean right like that's
the standard like he's he's doing kind
of like people compared to like George
Carlin yeah Carlin for a while was like
a jokey joke guy and then later in his
career he's like angry at the end yeah
[Applause]
yeah we'll set people on fire but like
we're still jokes but still talking
about real stuff right like you said the
influencing part because I think a lot
of people looked for comedians for truth
and inspiration and actually having no
filter because they're like oh they're
not they're not backed by big
corporations
sponsored by Pfizer or whatever whatever
exactly
yeah I'll buy athletic greens you know
and better help but but that's how it
goes like they see them as those
individuals so it's easier for them to
be like yeah that's what like they can
change how people think about stuff way
easier than like a news channel nowadays
it's funny because I don't know rainy
guys like class clowns coming up like in
school I definitely was like every
single year and it's like when you are a
Class Clown and you start to hang with
other class clowns like it is a very
specific type of people now I can
reflect how I look back and like oh we
were the kind of guys who weren't afraid
to break the rules not like in a cool
[__] way no we were just like we just
didn't see Authority the same with
everybody else we kind of always looked
outside the lines yeah and right those
are the people you might want to go to
to like hear some [__] to shake up your
own perspective yeah but if you keep
shooting those people down or if like
that lane keeps closing and it becomes
just like making [__] funny gym
videos if that's the thing
[__] are we do yeah one of my favorite
Clips is of Chappelle he's had like a
small comedy club in the east coast and
he was talking about how why comedy is
so sacred and he was like every single
thought different thought that you can
have in America that opinion is being
championed by at least one stand-up
comedian somewhere and that idea is
being pushed out there being tested
against people flipped around so like
they are technically like the purveyors
of free speech and even dissecting and
understanding what Free Speech means so
that's why we have to keep comedy alive
and I'm like damn that's deep that's
facts I wonder what happened though
because it's not like stand up I mean
the people that are probably complaining
now they they were probably alive when
things were you know different ten five
years ago so like what changed because
people would say gen Z soft but most of
the people that are complaining I would
see different ages I think the topics
change but I think the essence of Comedy
never really went anywhere because like
although it has like podcasts and
specials Tick Tock whatever there's so
many different forms of Comedy but what
didn't change like what it would have
what have you guys noticed that did not
change in comedy
the bit the big related the one thing I
do like about like not one thing I like
a lot of things about like Tick Tock is
that um
you know the big relatable videos that
everyone can laugh at I really
appreciate those yeah the quick ones
that like no matter who you are everyone
thinks this is yeah yeah there's
something special about that you know I
mean I think Tick Tock put a lot more of
those at the Forefront like a Chinese
guy getting kicked in the nuts right
always I'll never not be funny
yeah like I'm not a comedy slot snob I
love slapstick yeah like like three
stooges kind of stuff like fart jokes
like it would never be not funny yeah
like just simple Primal stuff yeah even
fart jokes like I'm like a cerebral
level like you're just making fun of
something everybody does right but I'm
sure somebody else might take [__]
seriously yeah yeah we all fart IBS dude
that's [__] up
as a writer did how often do you run
into the situation where like because I
know you write so much stuff for
yourself but since you also work in the
industry and sometimes you might have to
work with producers how often does it
come to a point where somebody uh
disapproves of something you've written
and they're like changed that like two
PC reasons yeah for any reason yeah it
happens that happens a lot yeah yeah I'm
pretty good at filtering those things
out though because I'm also like if I
think I'll fight for a joke too I'm like
no no this is gonna be okay and I'll
tell you why
I'll definitely Champion for like it to
go a little bit across the line
um but there definitely are if you're
putting a show like on a network like
there's a team of people and there's
another team another team people who are
ready to like read those scripts and be
like nah they just are looking out for
something that could like trigger
somebody and then even then you still
have the editing phase but can still cut
some [__] out yeah so there's a lot of
people in the way of like you know
risque jokes happening but it happens
all the [__] time have you been in
the situation yet where you're like
writing a film and then MPAA comes in
and says you're gonna get an R rating if
you leave this in or something like that
we'll see with this one right now like
we'll see what happens like it probably
oh no it'll definitely be a r rating
this okay yeah but like I don't know
what else I'm gonna slap us with I'll
send you one of the scripts that we
wrote and I really like this one as 30
seconds okay it's our MMA movie and at
the time this is pre-covered we sent to
a bunch of Studios
is one person like the person that read
it he was just like this is absurd like
and he was just I was just like honestly
this is like one of the funniest things
I've ever read or we haven't worked on
because even thinking about just every
scene is just so ridiculous
like there's this one part I don't want
to ruin the movie even though we're
never gonna make it but
Dad he's a deadbeat dad that is divorced
with his wife and his wife hates him and
his kid thinks he's
a wag it and uh
and he yeah yeah and but he's trying to
rekindle he's a spider that's trying to
rekindle his relationship with his with
his son in the most heart-to-heart
moment of the film like mid act two
while he's trying to have a
heart-to-heart moment with this uh with
his kid his ex-wife's getting railed in
the back so it's like
that's good oh yeah yeah and then he's
trying to like explain to his kid like
why he hasn't been around
I remember getting notes back
this is absurd or whatever and I was
like man you guys what that literally
happened in Forrest Gump that's true
yeah
[Music]
yeah and there's no way anything in that
movie is more ridiculous than cocaine
[__] Bear yeah oh yeah that's true
about a bear who gets high on coke and
runs through the force that's the other
part of I think like Hollywood that's
important is the networking because if
the wrong person reads your project yeah
oh that's just goes to the bottom
somewhere right and the gatekeeping yeah
yeah depending on who's there yeah
because if he was like at the
representative of the studio but oh this
is tight
yeah
yeah dude don't give it don't let people
who you think don't let people read your
[__] if you aren't expecting a specific
kind of like perspective from them like
if I sometimes get feedback from people
I'm like yeah but like you're a cynics
like that's good I'm gonna take that
into this consideration or if someone's
like this is incredible yeah but like
you're too easy on stuff like I'll I'll
kind of meet you I think everything is
incredible yeah I never let one person's
opinion like tear me down or lift me up
too high I just kind of take it in the
context of like who they are like yeah
well you might think this is good or bad
because of that you know yeah other
people tell me [__] was track or no this
is like not it or you shouldn't do this
I'm like I [__] I sold the thing like
you were wrong yeah yeah what do you
think makes makes a good writing partner
ooh collaboration is a very special gift
or tool practice I think I think there
should be classes in college thought
about just collaboration because like
the art of like making somebody
something with someone else or with
another group of people like it's not
always easy like you have to be akin to
like
their inclinations are creatively also
just as a human like also like as like a
friend kind of like what sets them off
what gets them tired like what things
they laugh at like how do we get the
energy back so I think a good writing
part of collaborator is like someone
who's like flexible who's like down to
just kind of like Bend as you know
there's two people in the room like you
guys are different I think someone who
is doesn't take criticism so hard that
they like kill their [__] Mojo that's
the hardest thing I can't work with
people who I'm like be like this is a
good idea I'm like I might want to film
about the next one they're like oh [__]
and the rest of the day we can't [__]
work on anything because you're sad
about that one bad joke yes the whole
room got brought down yeah I will pitch
100 bad jokes I don't like that okay
next one like next one yeah did you ever
write a sketch about writing partners
because that's pretty fast
is it relatable because I feel like
anyone that's worked creatively in a
group knows exactly new projects for
high school same [__] yeah you know when
I feel like that but I'm trying to
figure out what to eat with my girl oh
it's to say anything into the first
thing no oh
[Laughter]
like why would you want that I don't
know
that kills collaboration so quick people
who can't take criticism like also like
if I think an idea is good I'm gonna put
you to you every day until you think
it's fun yeah yeah yeah I pitched it was
a sketch uh oh you guys know Steve Green
yeah
together on our Channel called like when
NFL refs if they play Fantasy Football
and like I that was an idea like I had
pitched Jimmy one you're like yeah what
if we do this thing he's like nah I'm
not seeing him okay and then a year
later he starts playing fantasy football
and hey what if we do this thing he's
like that's yes let's [__] do it yeah
yeah whatever like he wasn't feeling it
at the time yeah it wasn't the right
time to make that [__] yeah you actually
really like writing with Steve being
written four movies with them that's
great because we'll do like our
processes will book like a little
Retreat and then we'll get an Airbnb
like for four or five days that's the
way to do it so it's beginning and end
and then we have a one world rule
meaning like everyone is only looking at
that one screen so no one is off on
their phone or no one is off on their
computer because then now we're uh
disjointed so we can have pen and paper
but we're contributing to the one
project on the screen unless we have
breaks like oh damn [__] what was that
one thing we need to like do a little
bit of research like when were
motorcycles invented you know and then
we'll like all break off but then after
we're done we go back to yeah yeah and I
really like that rule that he said in
place so this is cool yeah sometimes we
take days where like
me and Jimmy like we had this one
hardcore writer's block rather show for
quibby a couple years ago and we were
stuck on this one episode for like
literally like six days which is crazy
for us we'd never get stuck for more
than like a day right or even half a day
and then like on the seventh day we were
just like should we just do a bunch of
mushrooms like [__] this
we're like yeah [__] this scriptures
and like two hours didn't like
the best ideas let me just I couldn't
run all this [__] down yeah like went
you know when I went to sleep woke up
like oh those ideas probably suck woke
up no dude it was the best script oh wow
but it really was just like taking the
edge off of like the pressure of like
what did I do about it yeah yeah getting
in there because for how long you guys
were in that rut for exactly just all we
could see was the rut just break away so
I guess that's flexibility right someone
was just like trying to say [__] this
it's just like yeah that's a great day
MMA movie I was talking about we wrote
with Steve
[Laughter]
[Music]